kandra's and magicians say that
scientists are the easiest sort of
people to fool because we believe what
we see and hear is a really good example
a perpetual motion machine and perpetual
motion machines are inherently
impossible they need energy to make the
wheel go round and you cannot create
energy out of nothing it has to have an
energy supply but if you look at this
wheel it is going round with no obvious
way of propelling it there's no motor
there all sorts of things around it it's
not clear how it works and this
perpetual motion machine belongs to me
it was built by my friend David Jones
who died last July 2017 and in his will
he bequeathed me this machine he built
it in 1980 or possibly 81 for an
exhibition of the British Association
this is a science festival that takes
place every year and it was displayed on
the stand of the magazine New Scientist
and people were asked to guess how it
worked in all the years since then since
1981 only one person may have guessed
the right answer and one of David's
friends has got pretty close and
everybody else has got it wrong so come
and let me show you it a bit closer
it's a bicycle wheel a perfectly
standard bicycle wheel with three funny
boxes on it
the coppers stand something down here
with heatsinks on it they're things that
look as if they might be magnets around
there and there's a box here labeled
Redco my friend David had a bogus
company that he wrote about in his funny
column called idlers column in the
journal New Scientist
it stands for dyed 'less research and
not sure what he stands for
and development company it was
completely bogus but quite often people
tried to sue him for patent infringement
I know because David was ill towards the
end of his life that this machine has
been running for more than two years
without any attention and it's a bit
slower than it went before so presumably
whatever it's mysterious energy source
it's running down but just before David
died I persuaded him to write me a
letter explaining how the machine works
here is the envelope is quite a funny
envelope
it's a reused envelope from the UK tax
authorities but you can see it says Sir
Martin Polyakov and it says here details
of pmm at one perpetual motion machine
one he built four of them David was the
only person in the world who ever made
and sold perpetual motion machines to
people who knew they were fraudulent but
they still bought them because they were
fun they're only two people have read
the letter me and Neil and because I
knew the secret would be safe with Neil
my guesses were completely wrong I
thought I'd solved it one night lying in
the bath I thought there was petrol in
these cans which was somehow being
oxidized then acting as a jet engine but
was completely wrong how did they react
he found that Neil is always inscrutable
you can never tell what he's thinking
unless it's when he's angry when they've
made a mess and he's clearing it up so I
think the answer is I don't know but I
know the secret is safe with him it's
much more interesting to speculate about
this than to know the answer I felt a
bit disappointed when I knew the answer
I felt a bit cheated oh it was that but
I hope you'll have fun thinking about it
too
[Music]
you still see the flame going down but
instead of going down in one great
whoosh eggs jumps up and down the tube
so it goes down a little bit and then up
and down and up and down and so on